Transcriber: Amna Ahmed
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
شيء يسعدني جدا ويشرفني أن أكون في
TEDx مسقط ضيافة ألفين وتسعة عشر.
سعيد بوجودكم جميعا في هذا الملتقى الرائع.
اليوم الـTopic شيء مختلف عما سبق،
ولكنه Topic مهم جدا وهو Topic
وهو matching مع أي Topic آخر.
هو عمل موازي مع أي عمل.
العمل التطوعي والعمل المجتمعي هو عمل ممكن
أن يتم بجوار أي أعمال أخرى أو من المفترض
أن يتم مع أي عمل من الأعمال
التي نقوم بها في حياتنا.
لو بدأنا ونقول على كلمتين ″الألم والأمل″
هم كلمتان من حروف متشابهة، ولكن
بالتأكيد الاختلاف بينهم كبير جدا.
التغيير بالألم
والتغيير بالأمل.
كل واحد من بيننا تعرض في
لحظة من لحظات حياته لتغيير.
لكن هل تغير بالألم أم
بالأمل؟ هذا هو الفرق.
في خريف ألفين وأربعة عشر، جاءتني مكالمة من
مديري المباشر، كنت أعمل وقتها مدير مكتب
كنت أعمل وقتها مدير مكتب لإحدى
المنظمات الخيرية التطوعية في كمبوديا.
المكالمة كانت كثيرا صادمة بالنسبة الحقيقة.
من لا يعرف كمبوديا، هي مملكة
على حدود مملكة تايلاند
سكانها حوالي خمسة عشر مليون نسمة
نسبة المسلمين فيها حوالي
خمسة في المئة تقريبا.
تعرضت كمبوديا لحرب
أهلية طاحنة في السبعينيات
كان أثرها شديد جدا على
إضعاف البنية التحتية لهذا البلد الصغيرة.
اثنين من كل ثلاثة في
كمبوديا تأثروا بهذه الحرب
إما بالقتل أو بالاختفاء أو بالتهجير.
كان القتل الممنهج في
هذه البلاد في هذا الوقت
أول ما أصاب، أصاب المتعلمين
والمثقفين وذوي العقول.
لأن أي سوء... أي حرب
أهلية أو أي إبادة
تطال هؤلاء أولا.
وظلت هذه الفترة خمس أو ست سنوات
أبيد فيها تقريبا  ثُلث الشعب الكمبودي،
وهذه كانت من أكبر الفاجعات في هذا الوقت.
انتهت الحرب تقريبا في سبعين في السبعينيات،
ولكن ظلت المناوشات حتى
سنة ثمانية وتسعين في كمبوديا.
بدأت بعدها كمبوديا تتطور
وتلحق بركب البلاد المتطورة.
في ألفين وتسعة، كانت أول
زيارة لي لإدارة هذا المكتب.
وبدأنا بالفعل نضع خُطَّة خمسية
للعمل على ثلاثة محاور رئيسية.
المحاور الاقتصادية، والصحية، والتعليمية.
نجحنا بفضل الله سبحانه في المحور التعليمي،
ولكن كان المحوران الاقتصادي والصحي
في تحديات كبيرة جدا بسبب أن معظم التبرعات
التي تأتي من المتبرعين كانت توجه إلى
بناء المساجد أو حفر
الآبار أو كفالة الأيتام.
بعضها كانت تمشي إلى كفالة طلاب العلم.
ولذلك، كانت أهم المشروعات التي
بدأناها هي مشروعات التعليم.
للعلم، المشاكل التي طالت المجتمع الكمبودي
وقتها لم تطلْ المسلمين فقط، بالعكس.
طالت كل أطياف المجتمع
فالفكر الشيوعي لا يفرق بين
دين ومذهب وطائفة أو خلافه.
فبدأنا في العمل في المرحلة الجامعية
والمرحلة الابتدائية، وحققنا نجاح كبير جدا
في كفالة أكثر من تسعين إلى مئة
طالب جامعي في هذه المرحلة.
لكن لم تكن كفالة دراسية،
إنما كانت كفالة ثقافية.
كنا نقدم لهم دورات تأهيل،
وتكنولوجيا، ورحلات.
فكان الطالب يخرج مباشرة إلى سوق
العمل بكل قوة، كان يحصل على
درجات ممتازة جدا في أعماله أول طبيب، أول
مهندس، أول محامي، أول مدرس في قريته
أو في مكانه. كان يدعو
Inspired the people to continuous study
أو كان يحمس الناس على التعلم في هذا المكان
ليكون قادرا على بناء بلده.
استطعنا بالفعل أن نحقق نجاح
رائع جدا في هذا الوقت،
ولكن للأسف كانت هذه المكالمة.
كثير من الجمعيات تضع شعار بناء الإنسان،
ولكن للأسف ليس كثير من المؤسسات التي
تحقق هذا فعلا على الأرض.
كانت المكالمة من مديري، “نحن للأسف سنتوقف
أو سنقوم بتسريح نصف
الطلاب الموجودين حاليا عندنا
لأننا معندناش تبرعات كافية بالنسبة لهم.”
متخيلين الموقف؟ متخيلين أن أنا عندي
تسعون أو مئة طالبا، أربيهم بهم بقالي سنتين
أو ثلاث سنوات.
باقي له سنتين ويتخرج، باقي له سنتين
ويبقى دكتور، أو مهندس، أو محاسب
باقي له سنة أو سنتين ويكون قائد في مجتمعه.
وفجأة، خلاص الموضوع انتهى؟
كان ألم كبير جدا بالنسبة لي في هذا الوقت
طلبت من مديري فقط عشرة أيام،
كي لا أتخذ القرار خلال عشرة
أيام فقط. وكانت بعض الرِّحْلات
رتبت معه بعض الرِّحْلات لبعض المتبرعين في
أكثر من بلدان، أغلبها بلدان من دول الخليج
وكانت أيضا المفاجأة الثانية بالنسبة
لي، ولكن هذه المرة مفاجأة كانت
سعيدة. استطالة أننا نجمع
الكفالات ليست لتسعين فقط،
بل لمائة وعشرين طالب وطالبة في عشرة أيام.
وهنا عرفنا الخلل.
الخلل ليس عندي. الخلل أننا لم ننقل
الصورة بطريقة صحيحة للمتبرع.
لم يستطع المتبرع أن يفهم الوضع الصح.
المتبرع، أو الداعم، أو المانح،
يجب أن تنقل له الصورة صح
أو يتم نقله داخل الصورة.
وبناء على هذا الموقف أو هذا
الألم، تكون عندي ثلاث قناعات
من أهم القناعات
التي ممكن أن تنجح أي مشروع عمل تطوعي أو
مجتمعي أو خيري في أي مكان، على حسب علمي.
أول شيء الاستدامة.
استدامة هذا العمل وضمان استدامته
بمشروعات وقفية استثمارية
تضمن استدامة العمل.
دون الرجوع إلى دعم المشروعات
أو تطلع على تبرعات.
الشيء الثاني هو الرِّحْلات
التطوعية الخيرية المجتمعية.
هذه تنقل الإنسان من بيئته
التي يعيش فيها إلى بيئة أخرى.
للأسف.
التبرع الآن.
يتم عبر كبسة زر.
كنا من قبل نتفاعل أكثر حتى مع الاحتياجات.
الآن ليس لدينا وقت نقرأ
دراسات أو نشوف أخبار.
التبرعات الآن أصبحت فزعات.
هيا أنتم في هذه الناحية تبرعوا...
وفلوس كثيرة جدا. ولكن لا
تصب في المصلحة، أو تصب في
بناء البشر لا بناء الحجر.
فالرحلة التطوعية تنقل المتبرع أو تنقل
الصورة كاملة إلى عقل وذهن المتبرع.
ومنه بالتالي إلى عائلته وأقربائه وجيرانه.
فالمتطوع الواحد يمكن أن يؤثر على مئة
أو ألف أو عشرة آلاف أو مئة ألف، على
حسب قدرته - مثلما قال الأخ صالح -
على  الـContact.
الشيء الآخر كان القيمة المضافة للتبرع.
أغلب المشروعات الكبيرة أو المشروعات
الضخمة أو المشروعات المؤثرة، تأتي عن طريق
مساعدات حكومية أو
لهيئات أو لمتبرعين كبار.
لكن المتبرعين الصغار اللي الـlimit
تباعهم في حدود ثلاثين أو خمسة وعشرون
ريال عماني، يقولون أنه
limit بسيط جدا، ما تفكيره؟
حسنا، سأعمل كسوة يتيم، أو سأعمل
طعام أو سأصنع مَكِنَة خياطة
لكن هذا ليس هذا صحيحا.
التبرع البسيط ممكن أن نضيف له قيمة
أكبر من قيمته بكثير جدا ونضعفها
لو قدرنا نعمل فكر ثاني.
الأفكار دي كلها
أنا اقتنعت بها.
واقتنعت بالتغيير، والتغيير اقنعني.
إذا لم تقتنع بالتغيير فلن تتغير، وإذا
اقتنعت بالتغيير فسيأتي لك التغيير
لعندك. وربنا سبحانه وتعالى
ييسر لك هذا الطريق.
بالتأكيد. فالله سبحانه
وتعالى يسيرني أو يسرلي
مجموعة من أروع الخلق في الحقيقة.
فهموا فكري.
شباب من كل الوطن العربي.
حتى من كندا ومن فرنسا  وألمانيا.
وأيضا كل دول الخليج، الأرْدُنّ،
المغرب، الجزائر، مصر، اليمن.
هؤلاء المجموعة من الشباب.
أنا أقول عليهم شباب لكن ممكن
أن يكون بينهم خمسين أوستين سنة،
ولكني أتكلم عن شباب القلب،
شباب العقل. الذين كانوا قادرين
على فهم معنى بناء الإنسان
أنا ابني بشرا وليس حجرا.
فاستطاعنا بالفعل أن نضع أسس
للعمل على هذه الثلاثة محاور
أو الثلاثة قناعات التي وضعناها.
فاستطاعنا أن نضع أسس لهذا الأمر.
أولا، أسسنا مؤسسة Relief 4 Life.
وهي مؤسسة غير ربحية في ماليزيا.
مؤسسة مرخصة للعمل في الأعمال الغير ربحية
في كل العالم. وبدأنا أن
نضع خُطَّة لهذه الأعمال.
كان من أهم الثلاثة قناعات، القيمة
المضافة للتبرع. هم كلهم مهمين،
ولكن هذه كانت شيئا رائعا جدا. عندما نقول
ثلاثين ريال عماني أو خمس وسبعين دولار
هذه قيمة ليست كبيرة. لكن قدرنا
في سلة خيرات نعمل Package.
الـPackage يحمله خمسون شخصا لمدة سنة.
يضع فيه خمس وسبعين دولار
أو ثلاثين ريال في كل شهر.
هذا الـPackage داخله بيت، وعيادة،
وكفالة يتيم، وكفالة طالب، وكفالة مدرس.
خمسة عشر مشروعا، تصب فيهم خمس
وسبعين دولارا، وآخرهم المشروع الوقفي.
المشروع الوقفي، يعمل رِيْع
ويضخ مرة ثانية في نفس السلة.
فبعد أربع خمس أو ست سنوات
يكون رِيْع المشروع الوقفي
الذي يضخ في السلة. لا نحتاج أصلا إلى
الضخ الزيادة، ولكن أصبح ضخ آلي...
ضخ ذاتي للمشروع خلال ست سنوات.
ويستمر عمل المشاريع بآلية وباستدامة
بدون أي توقف أو بدون الحاجة
إلى أي من التبرعات الزيادة.
طبعا السوشيال ميديا كانت العامل
الحاسم في نجاح هذا الأمر الثاني.
لكي أجمع خمس وسبعين دولارا من كندا
ومن فرنسا ومن أمريكا، ومن هنا وهناك
أمر صعب جدا.
فكان نشر الفكرة أصلا، وجمع التبرعات
عبر السوشيال ميديا كان شيء
مهم جدا بالنسبة لنا. قدرنا بالفعل أن
نحقق مشاريع نوعية على الأرض.
تعليم قد يكون
تعليم نوعي، هذا في كمبوديا. التابلت في
كمبوديا... لا أعرف ما أقل لكم... حصل
كهرباء في كمبوديا حتى ليست
معروفة. أننا نعمل بيوت للفقراء
إننا نعمل طبعا... احتياجات اللاجئ في
الروهينغي في ماليزيا، هي نفس احتياجات
اللاجئ اليمني في جيبوتي.
احتياجات أهل النيجر من المياه، هي  نفسها
الصومال. احتياجات الرجل في أندونيسيا أو
في سريلانكا لعمل مشروع اقتصادي
يستطيع أن ينمي نفسه به
احتياجات مهمة جدا قدرنا نعملها.
وأكيد لو زرت موقعنا على
الـWebsite ستجد فيه معلومات أكثر.
الوقف الخيري.
الاستدامة.
استطعنا أن ننشأ حتى الآن مجموعة من
الأوقاف الزراعية في كمبوديا، وإن شاء الله
يليها بعض الأوقاف الأخرى.
نحن قلنا خمسة عشر مشروعا، منهم وقف خيري.
بأخد الوقف الخيري وبعمل به مشروع إنتاج
يضخ مرة ثانية في السلة
بعد خمس أو ست سنوات؛
حتى ما احتاج للمتبرع الذي
يأتيني بخمسة وسبعين دولارا.
الرِّحْلات التطوعية. وهذا
عالم آخر من الإلهام.
الـBus فيه حوالي سبع جنسيات.
ومثلما ترون، اغلبه ما شاء الله شابات.
تحية لكل الشابات اللاتي حضرن معنا اليوم.
الرحلة التطوعية هي تحدي، ولكن أثرها
غير طبيعي. يعني أثرها على المتطوع
وعلى صاحب الرحلة، يكاد يكون
أثر لن ينساه طوال عمره.
يشعر قلبه بالامتنان
لله عز وجل.
يشعر قلبه بالحب.
يشعر قلبه بالخير.
ليس هم من يحتاجوا لنا
نحن من نحتاج إليهم.
نحتاج إليهم كي نربي انفسنا.
نحتاج إليهم كي نعرف قيمة
دفتر الورق الذي بأيدينا...
كوب المياه الذي نشربه...
دورة المياه التي ندخلها...السرير
الذي ننام عليه... اللقمة التي نتناولها.
فالامتنان لله عز وجل من أكثر الأشياء التي
نستفيدها من هذه الرحلة. شيء آخر
كم مرة فكرت أنك تدفع تبرع لمؤسسة
وتفكر مئة ألف مرة هل هذا التبرع
يصل أم لا؟ عندما تذهب بنفسك ليس معناه
انك ستذهب بنفسك كل مرة، لكن فقط
تذهب مرة كي تري بعينك.
وتكون قادر على تقيم الأمور، كيف تسير؟
وغيرك يمشي وراك وغيرك يتابعك، وإلى آخره.
طبعا كان في ألم وفي أمل،
لكن كان هناك أحلام.
أحلامنا هي أن ننقل هذه الخبرة إلي أولادنا
وبناتنا. لذلك كنا نصطحب دائما في
كل سنة من رحلتنا كل شهرين تقريبا
كانت رحلة منهم تخصص للأشبال بطريقة معينة
آمنة، بحيث يستفيدوا من هذه الأمور ويكون
لديهم في المستقبل هذا الفكر، وهذا الرقي،
وهذا الحب، وهذا البذل، وهذا العطاء له
وللمجتمع.
أخيرا.
إذا كنت أنت
أو كان الأمل لنفسك فأنت بتشتغل عليه كويس.
عندما يكون الأمل لأسرتك
ولعائلتك، يكون التحدي أكبر.
لكن عندما تكون أنت الأمل
لناس بسطاء أو محتاجين
بالتأكيد يكون التحدي أكبر وأكبر،
والجهد يكون أكبر وأكبر.
إن شاء الله نلقاكم في عالم البذل
والحب والخير والعطاء إلى لقاء قريب.
السلام عليكم.
شكرا.